samedi à 22 heures sur public sénat
gérard longuet vice président de l'ump
sénateur de la meuse est l'invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir tout le monde
merci d'être avec nous pour ce rendez
vous avec dailymotion avec l' agence
france-presse représenter tout à l'heure
par notre consoeur nadège paul jacquet
alors que perrine tarneaud comme chaque
semaine de public sénat nous rejoindra
pour la dernière partie cette émission
du non lieu de nicolas sarkozy à
l'offensive du front national que rien
ne semble arrêter de la situation
économique aux réformes et à votre
accusation osé avec plusieurs de vos
collègues ump au sénat d'un porche
actuelle vers le collectivisme les
sujets et les questions ne manquent pas
gérard longuet d'abord évoquons françois
hollande et manuel valls qui était en
visite ce mardi le premier dans la loire
le second à forbach en moselle même
motivation lutter contre la colère
contre la désespérance contre la
frustration le sentiment d'abandon et
puis également intensifier la lutte
contre l'insécurité et le chômage mais
on a également appris dans le même temps
l'hémorragie des emplois chez alcatel
lucent dix mille suppressions nettes de
postes partout dans le monde 900 en
france
l'état doit-il petit ne se contentait de
demander un plan social le moins
douloureux possible
enfin vous avez évoqué et beaucoup de
sujets voulait commencer par lequel un
caténaire
alcatel lucent nous démontre une fois
encore qu'une entreprise pour rester
leader doit être mondiale gagner de
l'argent et investir alors
malheureusement alcatel lucent a perdu
son leadership mondial au bénéfice
d'acteurs d'autres pays et qui ont eu
les marges plus importantes qui ont
investi qui ont pu prendre des risques
parce que leurs résultats leur
permettaient alors qu'alcatel lucent est
dans une position défensive depuis plus
de 15 ans ces comptes sont dans le rouge
ces comptes sont dans le rouge et quand
vous n'investissez pas vous perdez cette
position de leader qui seule permet de
fixer les emplois en europe
alors aujourd'hui le président de cette
société franco américaine reconnaît que
le plan social et douloureux
très très très difficile qu'est ce que
peuvent faire les autorités les
autorités peut faire énormément de
choses contrairement à ce qu'on croit
même dans une rue et dans un pays ouvert
dans un pays dont les frontières sont
libres à un gouvernement à la
responsabilité de la productivité du
pays sur le long terme refusé par
exemple essentiellement massif so lu
ment pas c'est la question qu'un
gouvernement doit se poser c suis-je en
train de donner à mon pays toutes les
chances pour ces entreprises de gagner
de l'argent
la réponse est non avec ce gouvernement
et c'était pas terrible avant mais avec
ce gouvernement c'est carrément non les
mamans je veux dire par là des 35 oui je
sais ça ne m'a pas échappé et les 35
heures nous les avons encadré
libérez nous avons fait le maximum n'ont
pas tout fait et aujourd'hui choqués de
constater que la productivité la
compétitivité v français s'est dégradée
par rapport non pas la chine ce qui met
par rapport ce tout simplement
l'allemagne notre voisin alcatel lucent
paye globalement et pas simplement en
france parce que c'est une affaire
américaine et internationale
elle paye le fait d'avoir perdu pied
progressivement de ne pas avoir
reconstitué les marges et une entreprise
qui ne gagne pas l'or c'est un message
très simple une entreprise qui ne
gagnent pas l'argent n'assure pas
d'avenir à ses salariés il faut accepter
cette purge
l'état ne peut pas faire autrement parce
qu'il ne va pas subventionner alcatel il
ne va pas nationaliser alcatel c'est une
affaire absolument mondiale ne peut pas
non plus l'air diriger parce qu'il n'a
pas les compétences pour le faire il
faut bien savoir que l'état ne s'est pas
dirigé un groupe électronique
professionnelle mondiale ce que peut
faire l'état c'est en effet un plan
social est lié à ce que le plan social
soit le plus parfait possible et surtout
pour l'avenir se donner les moyens
d'aider les entreprises ou plus
exactement de donner aux entreprises des
conditions de réussite
le crédit impôt recherche est une vraie
réussite il faut continuer de soutenir
ses opérations là et puis je pense aussi
une autre une autre option pour la
france est que nous avons des points
forts nous avons des points faibles
m s'il y a un peu d'argent public
notamment le crédit impôt recherche le
mettre sur les secteurs où nous sommes
forts
pense l'aéronautique le spatial je pense
l'énergie l'énergie nucléaire se donner
les moyens d'être les meilleurs là où
sommes déjà fort est ce que on peut pas
être bon partout
vous reconnaissez quand même les efforts
du gouvernement pour favoriser la
compétitivité des entreprises je ne les
vois pas je ne vois pas si on parle du
ceis île dont on ne sait pas comment il
sera payé et qui va se traduire in fine
et vraisemblablement par une charge sur
la production c'est à dire sur les
entreprises les entreprises depuis 18
mois ont supporté je crois enfin une
addition en milliards d'euros
considérable
le gouvernement vient de renoncer à la
taxation de l'excédent brut
d'exploitation tant mieux c'était une
folie absurde qui allait tuer
l'investissement il va doubler un impôt
qui l'a retrouvé à cette occasion donc
mais pourquoi la charge fiscale augmente
parce que le gouvernement n'a pas
renoncé
le travail en france la compétitivité
française comme nous ne gagnons pas de
parts de marché à est évident qu'on est
obligé d'augmenter les impôts ce que
nous ne gagnons pas l'exportation et
nous sommes obligés de le payer par les
impôts alors nous parlons est trop
sacrifié oui oui nous parlons économie
longuet chacun s'accordent à voir en
françois hollande un social-démocrate
bontin même s'il ne s'assume pas
forcément et vous donc je disais avec 16
autres sénateurs ump ont ri la france
aucune excuse et dans le collectivisme
n'est ce pas un excès qui rappelle quand
même des critiques de 1981 lors de
l'élection de françois mitterrand alors
l'auteur de cet as de ce communiqué
jean-noël cardoux que je soutiens en
l'espèce complètement à stigmatiser une
mesure qui est la collectivisation du
risque sur le locataire c'est à dire que
le gouvernement de lancer sa simple la
loi duflot le gouvernement de lee c'est
très simple les locataires ne payez pas
d'ombré faire une assurance qui sera
obligatoire les propriétaires et des
autres locataires vont payer ça veut
dire que collectivement nous allons
propriétaires et locataires vont se
trouver obligé de payer pour les mauvais
locataires que va-t-il se passer s'est
créé mauvais locataires se sentant
protégées en une bombe
il y aura une assurance je planterai une
ardoise chez mon propriétaire et je
dirais aux proprios mon vieux aller voir
l'assurance c'est du collectivisme
mais qui s'applique à une seule mesure
qui s'applique ses loisirs mais
tendresse où il rassure favori n'a pas
tout à fait compris alors la situation
sociale alimentant tous les cas le front
national manuel valls a entrepris un
tour de france des régions où il est en
pointe est ce que vous le voyez le
ministre de l'intérieur comme un rempart
efficace contre l'extrémisme il est en
contradiction totale avec sa majorité il
appartient au gouvernement de madame
taubira qui est en ce moment même est en
train de multiplier les signes
extrêmement fort de complaisance de
sollicitude de mansuétude avec les
délinquants
comment voulez vous que ce gouvernement
soit créé des monsieur valls est
certainement un homme de conviction il a
son franc parler ça ne me choque pas
mais ça n'aura si ce n'est pas rassurant
pour autant parce qu'une action
gouvernementale c'est une action
collective et jusqu'à présent lorsqu'il
ya une décision collective
elle tombe dans l'escarcelle de madame
taubira garde des sceaux présentait la
récente énergie sera non seulement
présenter mais sans doute adopter
or c'est une réforme absurde puisque
comme le dit jean françois copé
elle se fonde sur l'idée que puisque a
pas de place en prison laissant les
délinquants dehors mais ça c'est une
idée qui a court aussi parmi vos
collègues mais là je décide également
gérard longuet les peines de probation
seront été soutenu par par l'uimm est en
droit d'avoir plusieurs avis mais
globalement civile et le fait carcérale
est un élément dans tous les cas de
aller de retraite ça tombe de l'un quand
période active alors que les prisons
étaient des défauts j'en suis le premier
convaincu je visite celle de mon
département entre l'hygiène la
promiscuité et la complicité et parfois
le la transmission des informations à
l'intérieur des prisons les prisons ne
sont pas parfaites mais donner la
certitude de la liberté
c'est l'appel à la délinquance alors il
ne peut attaquer en diffamation ce qui
signifie son parti d'extrême droite est
ce qu'elle nie l'évidence oui enfin ça
dépend
mon sentiment personnel c'est que quand
vous avez des positions quand vous avez
des positions extrêmes de rupture sur
des sujets comme en effet l'europe
l'identité française sur l'autorité sur
les acquis sociaux
vous êtes extrêmement c'est à dire que
vous êtes extrêmement hostile à tout ce
qui fait la france d'aujourd'hui
donc c'est un parti d'extrême droite
c'est ta partie de rupture et donc
d'extrémisme et en particulier sur un
sujet qui est au coeur de l'avenir
français qui est l'euro et la
construction européenne madame le pen
j'ai lu un peu son programme ferme les
frontières abandonne l'euro c'est un
extrémisme économique qui va entraîner
d'autres extrémismes
parce qu'évidemment de proche en proche
c'est toute la société qui serait
reprise en main par l'autorité de
politique si le front national avait des
responsabilités ce qui je le pense
profondément n'aura pas lieu le porte
parole des députés ps demandent on parle
lui d'un parti national fasciste en
raison de ses présidences history sur
les minorités sur les corps
intermédiaires mais la référence est
historique et c'est un chiffon rouge qui
sert les intérêts du front national vous
l'avez noté jean langlais la gauche
appellent à faire barrage contre le
candidat du front national extrémistes
dimanche prochain à la cantonale de
brignoles dans le var
donc la gauche reste fidèle au front
républicain c'est un geste vous
appréciez la gauche et l'aide elle a
dévissé dans l'électorat populaire il
n'existe plus dans l'électorat populaire
élan tire les conséquences soit mais
elle ferait mieux de se poser la
question de savoir pourquoi le front
national existe et en partie parce que
justement les annonces de madame taubira
ne inquiète les français et les amène à
accepter des positions extrémistes
c'est madame taubira qui fait le front
national valls ne l'empêchent pas et si
les socialistes veulent nous soutenir
j'en suis très reconnaissant en général
ils ont bénéficié des voix du front
national pour faire battre des députés
ump ce fut mon cas en 1997 je m'en
souviens donc vous êtes reconnaissants
quand même à cette attitude républicaine
je pense qu'ils n'ont pas d'autre choix
et je suis très heureux pour notre
candidate qu'elle est ce soutien car ça
lui sera utile car le seul sera
indispensable
oui absolument sinon elle ne peut pas
gagner la gauche n'a pas de doute donc
apparemment pour savoir qui est le plus
sectaire en train une ump en l'espèce
bien c'est tout ça parce que les ump
sont souriants icmp titre ce qui n'est
pas toujours le cas des amis de monsieur
mélanchon front national un doute pour
savoir qui est le plus expert
humainement si vous voulez je ne ferai
pas la zoologie complète de toute la
carte politique française ya
certainement des gens sympathiques un
peu partout je dis simplement que le
front national n'apporte rien notre pays
et que le ps le tire vers le bas et
qu'il est de son complice c'est là que
le ps gagne parce que le front national
existe un quart des électeurs se dit
prêt à voter front national aux
prochaines élections municipales gérard
longuet selon un sondage lh2 le nouvel
observateur qu'est ce que vous dites
vous aux sympathisants ump
je crois qu'ils sont un sur deux à
pencher pour des alliances avec la seule
façon pour land de se sortir du mauvais
pas dans lequel il engageait notre pays
et sa majorité c'est de jouer avec le
front national
et comme mitterrand a su le faire en son
temps en 88 enfin dans un passé lointain
nous avons affirmé nos convictions nos
valeurs à être en tête au premier tour
et de telle sorte que après les
électeurs choisissent être en tête au
premier tour c'est la logique de l'ump
ce qui pourrait d'ailleurs que l'une des
responsabilités de l'ump c'est d'abord
de garder tous les siens et d'être
suffisamment sympathique et attractive
pour s'élargir y compris vers le centre
je pense que le centre a une
responsabilité historique
si le centre veut travailler seul il
permettra au front national d'être au
deuxième tour et il porterait une
responsabilité assez lourde au je pense
que l'un des problèmes on en parlera
peut-être ses caisses que le délit
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que le modem
aujourd'hui séparés ils contribuent à
donner la perspective d'un deuxième tour
ps front national vous êtes satisfait du
retour au bercail comme l'écrivait
jacques julliard dans marianne cette
semaine de françois bayrou
françois bayrou qui compte un
conditionnement il a sa personnalité il
est parfois agaçant il est souvent
imaginatif et généreux en tous les cas
ils aiment la politique et il la connaît
bien
vous êtes satisfait de son envie
rationnelle je préfère la qu'ailleurs
nous allons évoquer maintenant le retour
de nicolas sarkozy avec nadège pile
jacques de l'agencé france presse ancien
président est donc libéré du boulet de
l'affairé bettencourt mais politiquement
il a encore d'autres écueils sur sa
route judiciaire d'abord et puis
politique ensuite ainsi françois fillon
qui se dit aujourd'hui prêt pour
l'affrontement
sophie normand on le connaissait poser
modéré et rassembleur on le découvre
combatif dur et impétueux depuis
plusieurs semaines françois fillon
multiplie les sorties
dernière en date dans le journal du
dimanche l'ancien premier ministre
s'affranchit et lâche le mot rupture
il a un objectif les primaires de 2016
il faut qu'ils font de l'armure il faut
qu'il devienne lui même et ils prennent
un certain nombre de libertés
c'est pas le libre c'est ce que les
français attendent de lui changement de
style
mais pour ce proche de nicolas sarkozy
la rupture est fondamentale le premier
signal a été donné il ya un mois
françois fillon appelait alors à voter
pour le moins sectaires en cas de duel
ps fn y droitise l'image parce qu'ils
pensent que notre lectorat est en
droitiser ça vaut mieux pour la primaire
et si nicolas sarkozy revient je pense
qu'il est un sujet c'est que cet
électorat là ce sera plutôt pour sarkozy
et et son image
autrefois plus centriste plus modérée
lui aurait permis d'avoir un autre
électeur il fait un pari sur 2016 un
pari qui passe par une compétition
directe ce sont ses mots avec nicolas
sarkozy à qui il n'a plus parlé depuis
plusieurs mois fini donc l'image de
collaborateurs de l'ancien président le
député de paris veut se démarquer de
celui qui pour beaucoup de militants ump
restent considérés comme le recours
providentiel pour 2017 françois fillon
dit se libérer et affirme travailler sur
un programme lui aussi de vraies
ruptures une stratégie un peu décalé
pour jean pierre raffarin
je ne conteste ni la légitimité ni la
qualité de françois fillon ni les idées
simplement ce que je dis c'est que cette
logique du quinquennat qui nous oblige
est en campagne présidentielle fait
qu'aujourd'hui on tient le discours de
2017 en 2013 et pour les français je le
dise sérieusement c'est décalé des
français qui continuent de plébisciter
nicolas sarkozy dans les sondages contre
la cote de françois fillon pâli alors la
stratégie d'affrontement ouverte
françois fillon envers nicolas sarkozy
est ce que c'est la bonne stratégie
je vais absolument incapable de porter
un jugement sur une stratégie
présidentielle ayant à titre personnel
jamais été convié à bercy tient vous
êtes un soutient monsieur fillon vous
devez quand même avoir une place et ses
convictions j'apprécie son comportement
j'apprécie son expérience et j'ai passé
dans son gouvernement sous l'autorité du
président de la république c'est le cas
du ministre de la défense des moments
parfaits maintenant dans la vie
politique française raffarin lisait
l'instant le fait présidentiel semble
tout écraser or il y a une vie politique
avant 2017
cette vie politique et les
parlementaires elle est partisane elle
est les municipales elle sera cantonales
et régionales en 2015 sénatoriales aussi
très franchement comme disait chirac ça
me fait ça me touche une sans faire
bouger l'autre parce que c'est joliment
dit
c'est du chirac dans le texte oui je
sais que c'est difficile de la tête mais
j'aurais quand même revenir
caractère fillon un homme de son âge et
son expérience et envie d'afficher sa
personnalité et de dire je ne suis pas
là simplement pour être un assistant un
collaborateur c'est son droit le plus
strict et je pense que sa démarche
enrichit la vie politique exacte sa
transgression
parce que s'ils voulaient manger très
grande fidélité sympathie reconnaissance
à nicolas sarkozy mais c'est agréable
dans un dans une vie politique d'avoir
plusieurs talents il se trouve que parmi
les talents qui se confirme ou qui
émerge françois fillon en fait partie
très clairement à un niveau d'ambitions
qui supervise en province lors des lions
d'ambition quand même non à la question
si je ne voulais pas répondre à la
question de la question très franchement
ne me concerne pas je vous avais pas
tiré sur l'existence de dieu genève le
seigneur si aujourd'hui un malentendu
alors là je m'engage en politique par
conviction je ne suis pas un homme d'une
femme d'ailleurs j'ai des convictions
libérales républicaine européenne je
suis décentralisateur je crois à
l'économie d'entreprise et ce qui
m'intéresse c'est que ces valeurs soient
défendus au président à chaque combat et
en particulier aux présidentielles qui
auront lieu en 2017
tout comme je les connais tous et compte
tenu ma longévité politique je les
connais en général entre 30 et 45 ans
donc si vous voulez il y a peu de
chances que le chemin de damas mme fu
droit sur une route de l'assemblée
entre françois fillon et nicolas sarkozy
vous semble le plus à même de défendre
vos idées que vous avez rappelé votre
positionnement libéral parce qu'il
semble que nicolas sarkozy se détache de
ce positionnement l'a d'ailleurs il a
reproché à françois fillon de vouloir se
faire élire en promettant la retraite à
65 ans ou en promettant en français mais
qu'ils allaient travailler 39 heures
payées 35 rhums de l'ump d'ailleurs de
monsieur copé pour le prendre là le
titre de livre de françois fillon la
france accepte la vérité et la vérité
c'est qu'on travaille pas assez par
rapport aux allemands qu'on se commence
trop tard quand s'arrête trop tôt
le moins d'heures par semaine et que
cela est un vrai problème pour notre
compétitivité tout à l'heure vous nous
avez rappelé vous avez été ministre
justement sous la présidence de nicolas
sarkozy
ça veut dire la défense me la défense si
la défense comme vous savez
constitutionnellement est en fait
rattachée au président alors le françois
fillon était premier ministre
photo nicolas sarkozy était le président
vous les avez vu fonctionner ensemble
tous les deux et quand c'était
l'ambiance c'était les tricks entre eux
non parce que si vous voulez françois
fillon est quelqu'un qui joue le jeu
qu'on lui assigne quand il est premier
ministre un président de la république
il se comporte comme le premier ministre
un président de la république de la
cinquième quand il est candidat à
exister proprio mots tu es sûr ça avec
son enseigne bien il fait ce café
georges pompidou à rome dès lors
l'ancien on va on va revenir sur un
monsieur sarkozy est le non lieu d'hier
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour l'ump
c'est une bonne nouvelle dans la justice
d'abord ça prouve que la justice est
indépendante et qu'elle n'a pas cédé
l'acharnement qui qui qui frappait
nicolas sarkozy les attendus des juges
qui sont dures ou qui sont sévères est
ce qu'ils peuvent jeter la suspicion sur
monsieur sarkozy juge mentionne dans l'
ordonnance de non lieu effectivement un
comportement abusif
de nicolas sarkozy lors de sa ou ses
visites au domicile des bettencourt
je ne sais pas si le jeu n'est pas lui
c'est attendu je dis simplement qu'il
n'ya pas lieu de poursuivre nicolas
sarkozy était en cours et que son mari
andré bettencourt qui était également un
ami et reçus ont familiarité le maire de
neuilly qui était maire depuis 25 ans de
leur ville s'est pas complètement
anormal il est normal qu'ils aient
distribué des enveloppes pendant des
années ce avons prouvé que certains
surfent depuis fi
c'est un secret de polichinelle je
regarde qu'une seule chose c'est qu'il
n'en ait pas donné au parti républicain
quand je t'ai trésorier parce qu au
moins ça nous aurait aidés mais à partir
du moment où ce n'est pas interdit par
la loi pourquoi de leur ville pas fait
alors sur sa page facebook
hier monsieur sarkozy avait évoqué ceux
qui l'ont soutenu mais aussi les
responsables politiques un joli sa
phrase qui ont participé à cultiver le
soupçon à son égard les fillonnistes
dont vous faites partie est ce qu'elles
doivent se sentir visé pas du tout alors
qu'il faisait qui alors des qui parler
de la question et on y montera pas quand
on l'invitera michel d'autres positions
mais dans mon cas particulier je connais
bien la justice et je connais bien son
fonctionnement j'ai bénéficié de quatre
noms de oui c'est ça de deux non lieux
et de quatre relaxes enr en
correctionnelle est en cour d'appel
confirmé donc j'ai jeûné
je sais ce que des ce qu'est être
soupçonné et ses os et nicolas sarkozy
s'imagine dans le sang une immense
libération je crois que c'est formidable
pour lui et ciblées la france a pas
tellement de talent qu'on puisse se
priver d'un homme d'énergie quoi qu'il
fasse même s'il s'occupe ce d'abord et
avant tout deux de communiquer et de
parler en comme il le fait en conférence
intérêt même faire plus mieux beaucoup
d'imagination et je pense qu'il peut
nous surprendre par les responsabilités
qu'il pourrait envisager d'assumer ces
poissons
moi je le vois je pense que
l'international à dimension européenne
dimension internationale et
naturellement la vocation d'un homme qui
était président de la république
française et qui a démontré dans les
crises internationales son aptitude à
agir dans l'action
place à l'union européenne quelque chose
comme ça je n'ai pas cette politique
intérieure jardon quai pour penser que
c'est une mauvaise piste pour lui c'est
une piste qui est tout vert et tout le
monde leur sentiment mon sentiment c'est
qu'il a une vraie dimension
internationale et que c'est un atout
pour notre pays qu'il pourrait mettre au
service de la france au titre
le gentil façon de rappeler qu'entre
nous sommes en 2013 et que 2010 est par
définition c'est dans trois ans et demi
réfléchissons entre nous nicolas sarkozy
suffisamment connue pour pas avoir
besoin de conduire une campagne de
notoriété
il connaît également on sait qu il
connaît les problèmes il connaît les
problèmes également at il besoin de
faire une campagne de trois ans et demi
pour les présidentielles la réponse est
absolument non il a besoin
en revanche j'en suis persuadé d'être un
homme dans l'action c'est un homme
d'action
quelles sont les actions dans les
institutions bloqué de la vème
république il n'y en a pas un chef de
parti oui c'est la seule qui soit ouvert
on avait l'impression qu'il soit très
différemment
finalement c'est tout à fait possible et
en 2017 sur un choix de candidat et je
participe au choix du client pour
nicolas temps de glisser que ce serait
un choix opportun selon vont les deux
peuvent se dire et on le verra en 2017
et expliquer s'il revient on peut
imaginer qu'ils participent à une
primaire la primaire à l'acte et
maintenant les débats dans les dents les
dans les statuts de l'ump beaucoup
travaillé charles pasqua sur le thème
des primaires
dans un passé récent et la grande
différence entre les etats-unis la
france il est c'est que aux états unis
le président des états unis je dirai pas
qui sort de l'inconnu mais il n'y a pas
de cursus honorum ce n'est pas
prévisible par exemple le poste de
premier ministre poste de chef de parti
n'existe pas on va chercher quelqu'un et
je rappelle qu aux etats unis également
la politique se fait à coups de millions
de dollars puisque on peut communiquer
librement en achetant des espaces en
france c'est tout à fait différent on
chemine progressivement vers la
notoriété
on est reconnu par son expérience la
primaire certes mais la primaire n'est
pas sera jamais en france et une
découverte
ça peut être dans certains cas s'il y a
nominale en voici une qui valence de
situation un moyen de départ cech enfin
deux jours parce que le lobby n'a pas
besoin non je pense que là la pause il
je devrais semblablement prudence mais
je préfère être prudent que péremptoire
ray semblablement l'opinion française
qui connaît ses hommes politiques
formulera un jugement alors avec un
bémol que vous connaissez bien
d'ailleurs qui est celui de 95 ou le
pignon semblait balladurienne et jacques
chirac a gagné la primaire elle vous
semble quoi aujourd'hui le client
l'opinion de toute façon il faut faire
restaurer une réalité simple c'est que
la droite modérée a le devoir absolu de
se mettre d'accord avant la
présidentielle
j'évoquais les centristes mais c'est
encore plus vrai et a fortiori pour
l'ump donc la mise en ordre de la
candidature est indispensable parce que
le front national sinon risque d'être
l'arbite de la présidentielle et comme
en 2002 nous proposer un choix
impossible au deuxième tour vous nous
parlez beaucoup de la droite modérée
tout à l'heure vous entendu dire l'ump
doit être attractive sympathique pour
attirer les électeurs du centre c'est ce
qu'on vous disiez à michel drucker
monsieur fillon
diba entre un ps fn choisissez le moins
sectaires est-ce que ça c'est
sympathique est-ce que c'est attractif
pour les électeurs du centre j'entends
un cépage manga leur jeu pour les
électeurs du centre mes mails sont les
électeurs à l'ump ça peut être en effet
surprenant si on ne connaissait pas
l'histoire même de françois feer moi je
vient de la droite et je sais que
françois fillon vient du gaullisme et
qu'il a été vis-à-vis le front national
13 n'a pas dit ça il a dit très
exactement
il a dit je ne veux pas qu'on m'impose
un prêt-à-penser et le prêt-à-penser
c'est qu'il se reconnaît le droit en fin
d'émission seul enfin messieurs il
arrive parfois que que l'on se lâche
il est en fin d'émission il s'est
reconnu le droit d'évaluer pour des
municipales la qualité des personnes
c'est ce que j'ai entendu
non mais c'est ce que j'ai entendu sur
europe
il s'est dit sûr une municipale je ne
peux pas qu'on m'impose un prêt-à-penser
et je dois reconnaître pour avoir
accueilli au parti républicain madame
yann piat le nom vous dit rien la seule
femme nue du front national en 1988 elle
l'acquitté os bout d'un an et non les
passer au parti républicain justement et
c'était une femme qui de qualité qui
s'était qu'ils s'étaient trompés sur le
sens profond du front national et
monsieur bompard n'est pas au front
national il a été élu avec cette
étiquette donc à tout pécheur
miséricorde
oui tout à l'heure vous avez parlé de
brignoles mais sur des justes vous poser
une question revenir là dessus
valérie pécresse a dit que soutien des
socialistes et des verts à la candidate
ump à bretignolles à brignoles et
c'était pas terrible finalement vous
montrez moi je voudrais savoir ce qu'est
ce que vous pensez
pourquoi maintenant quand on a dit ça ne
me dit pas demandez lui
on nous demandera quand on l'invitera
mais est-ce que ça se passe et tu avais
moi je pense que aussi des électeurs se
sont de gauche ou verts se rendre compte
de leur impuissance et en tire les
leçons
tant mieux c'est une leçon de modestie
et de réaliser leur part vous leur dites
merci par avance et je nom de la
candidate je pense que la candidate
faire merci va très bien après son
élection en suivra sa vision du lait car
pour vous c'est encore aussi lors
qu'elle gagne ça comme un but difficile
un point d'accès gauche parce que ça
fait 50 % quand on mentionne la
dissidence extrême droite quand on
additionne le front national leur
candidat extrêmement serré 49,4 avec
moins de participants
oui vous croyez qu'ils vont se déplacer
au deuxième tour vous avez osé y ait un
danger à manger on va pas regarder dans
la boule de cristal brignoles et si à
l'échelle et perrine tarneaud de public
sénat nous rejoint maintenant et c'est
notamment votre expérience de ministre
que nous allons solliciter maintenant
gérard longuet et notamment durant la
présidence mitterrand il faut le
rappeler
votre titre de ministre de la défense
pour analyser cette fois le style
hollande
puisque la question de l'autorité du
chef de l'état revient régulièrement
entre deux couacs ministériel jérôme
ramier au pouvoir depuis un an et demi
françois hollande élu sur une image de
rupture avec nicolas sarkozy subit
depuis les critiques sur son style
présidentiel manque d'autorité voire de
courage pour certains mais pour sa garde
rapprochée
il faut cesser de le comparer à son
prédécesseur shootée au sarkozysme il ya
un moment donné il va falloir que la
france se désintoxique très de
l'agitation perpétuelle l'agitation
perpétuelle c'est pas de l'autorité où
il faudrait donc s'habituer à une autre
forme d'autorité plus en douceur moins
médiatique celle de françois hollande
problème c'est bien avec un discours
sécuritaire et d'autorité que manuel
valls est devenu le ministre préféré des
français
valls incarne personnellement cette
autorité et c'est à travers l'autorité
que valls peut dégager que hollande et
héros apparaissent comme n'étant pas
assez autoritaire
ça s'est déjà passé il ya une dizaine
d'années et on s'en souvient ça
s'appelait nicolas sarkozy face à
jacques chirac et jean pierre raffarin
différence notable
jacques chirac était alors dans son
deuxième et dernier mandat alors que
françois hollande n'est qu'au début d'un
premier quinquennat le chef de l'état à
d'ailleurs déjà su imposer des choix
parfois avec autorité même si les couacs
gouvernementaux viennent ternir ces
décisions la sphère du mali la manière
dont il a dessiné aussi le pacte de
compétitivité de la manière dont il a
résisté à la rue sur le maire pour tous
donc on peut pas dire que françois
hollande soit quelqu'un qui manque
d'autorité
il n'y a plus un problème de charisme
une critique qui lui colle à la peau
puisque déjà lorsqu'il dirigeait le
parti socialiste certains le décrivait
comme un chef sans volonté de trancher
mais à l'image de ceux qui s'y sont
frottés à cette époque le président de
l'assemblée nationale reconnaît que sur
la durée
françois hollande a toujours su
s'imposer regardez le nombre de
critiques de ce genre qu'il a pu
affronter au moment où il était premier
secrétaire et je crois qu'il l'a
démontré à plus d'un ne confondez pas
son sourire et son autorité la méthode
hollande
au parti socialiste comme au sommet de
l'état a finalement peu champ
c'est l'art de la synthèse dont certains
se sont moqués est devenue la
concertation vanté comme méthode de
gouvernement
le président ne compte pas en dévier
même s'il l'a promis au prochain quoi
gouvernementale il saura trancher est-ce
que vous êtes de ceux qui pensent qu'il
ya une défaillance en matière d'autorité
à la tête de l'état je crois qu'il ya
une grande injustice a comparé françois
hollande et françois mitterrand françois
mitterrand est arrivé à la présidence au
terme d'un très long parcours politique
en connaissant des épreuves
invraisemblable dont il avait créé
parfois les conditions lui même et
c'était un combattant couvert de
cicatrices qui avait été non il n'a pas
connu les épreuves qu'a connues françois
mitterrand je pense pour avoir un an
comme valéry giscard d'estaing avait été
un combattant de volontaires de la
deuxième guerre mondiale il avait connu
les républiques difficile
l'incertitude de politique et il avait
combattu le gaullisme dans des
conditions certes interne mais qui était
de très forte tension
jacques chirac avait joué au contraire
le rôle du bon camarade qu'il n'était
pas nécessairement dans toutes les
circonstances soyez dans certaines mais
en revanche il jouait le rôle du bon
camarade il était ressenti comme tel par
nos compatriotes et s'il a battu s'il a
été si la battue edouard balladur en 95
c'est parce que justement il avait ce
préjugé de gentillesse de bonhomie le
bon sens avec la différence si vous
voulez c'est que il était vraiment le
patron de son camp alors que françois
hollande donne le sentiment d'être il
vous l'avais dit dans le reportage
l'homme des synthèses mais qui n'est pas
trop de personnes
piercing d'autorité vous aimeriez
aujourd'hui parce qu'on sait qu'il y en
a qu'une
y'en a qu'une c'est de garder ou de
faire partir quelqu'un est la condition
ne pas taper sur le plus faible
je vois quand et puisque juste à une
anecdote quand edouard balladur était
premier ministre
j'étais mise industrie bon il ya un écho
de presse qui ne convenait pas quand
votre premier ministre vous appelle à
7h15 du matin parce qu'il est déjà à son
bureau et vous êtes en train de prendre
vos croissant et vous du gérard j'ai
l'impression que là dessus on n'est pas
d'accord du tout ça s'arrête tout de
suite et ce set
il y a une autorité naturelle dont
olemps ii ne jouit pas naturellement il
ne faut pas non plus qu'il surjoue son
problème est très difficile il est innée
naturellement normal ça ne porte pas
l'autorité et si il surjoue l'autorité
il fera sourire fait coexister valser
taubira c'est un non sens complet il
fait coexister arnaud montebourg qui
aiment l'industrie pas toujours d'accord
avec lui et madame duflot ou n'importe
quel sac au dos qui tente industrielle
s'étend maintenant c'est un manque de
choix on a la pression mais la nappe
free qui cale à un membre de cap
politique l'autorité procède du moment
où vous prenez un risque parce que vous
voulez tenir un cap et jusqu'à présent
aujourd'hui
il a préféré éviter les risques et
abandonner le cap donc c'est un manque
de ligne politique claire
s'ils s'imposent tous chefs qu'ils
soient de guerre d'entreprise politique
de la constance dans le cap et de la
confiance profonde dans la validité de
ce cas je ne donne pas senti que
derrière le premier ministre dans sa
carrière c'est celui est-ce que c'est
l'effet le quinquennal fait matignon
soyons très clairs qu'elle est la seule
qui à quoi servait un premier ministre a
gagné les élections législatives
intermédiaires ou à être viré pour
gagner les élections législatives
intermédiaires il ya plus d'élections
législatives indiennes
la seule élection qui compte au soir du
deuxième tour des présidentielles
c'est le premier tour de cette
présidentielle suivante et entre temps
le premier ministre
sauf s'ils gèrent une majorité mais
quelle est la majorité qui a envie de se
déliter en cinq ans aucune
elle est élue dans le sillage la
présidentielle et les solidaires le
premier ministre a pas grand chose aux
grands absents des débats politiques en
ce moment c'est le parti socialiste
quelle place peut jouer le parti
majoritaire difficile si on l'est pour
avoir été dans un parti majoritaire avec
un président régnant que c'était vrai à
l'udf de giscard ou avec lui et
extraordinairement difficile on pensait
que les socialistes auraient une culture
de la liberté à travers cette tradition
des courants de temps en temps ça bouge
un petit peu à l'assemblée en termes de
propositions toujours les mêmes votes
on le verrait bien d'ailleurs sur les
retraites le gouvernement n'a de
majorité qu'avec le parti socialiste à
l'assemblée nationale
on verra bien s'il y a une défaillance à
l'intérieur du parti socialiste et je
suis persuadé qu'il n'y en aura pas le
socialiste n'existe pas parce que quand
vous n'êtes pas une source de pouvoir ou
une source d'incertitude où n'existaient
pas michel sapin le disais dans le che
convient de voir la france est encore
ajouté au sarkozysme il faut se
désintoxiquer de l'invitation il le
disait la semaine
hier c'est que certains départs et jt
calme au sein de plomb plomb c'est
d'ailleurs parce qu'il fait s'il tombe
sur les chiffres c'est lui le patron et
qui n'est bon c'est le gouvernement qui
donne les chiffres du chômage c'est pas
le sepa pôle emploi mais ce que vous
pensez comme chef sap en tant que la
france est en demande d'apaisement elle
est en manque de courage tranquille
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
le grand kiel qui sont les nuances c'est
très simple apaisement si ça consiste à
ne rien faire vous différer les
problèmes et ils sauront plus grave
après le courage tranquille ça consiste
à dire désolé les enfants ce qu'on a à
faire n'est pas drôle mais on va le
faire parce qu'une fois que c'est fait
on a rappelé à le faire c'est les
déficits c'est la productivité c'est le
temps de travail c'est des dépenses
sociales
ce sont des mesures d'autorité pour que
les professeurs soient respectées pour
que les services soient respectées pour
que des on a beaucoup progressé en
france il faut pas être moi je suis pas
du tout déclinistes regarder on a réussi
dans leur en matière de transports
publics grâce à des lois sarkozy à ne
plus avoir de grève inutile
et on peut travailler un certain nombre
de sujets sans mettre la france en
paralysie la france mûri il faut aller
beaucoup plus loin
beaucoup beaucoup plus loin est ce que
sarkozy lui il avait pêché par excès
d'activisme n'ont pas de moi si je n'ai
qu'un seul grief à l'encontre de nicolas
sarkozy c'est qu'il n'a il n'a pas
mich les français en face de leurs
responsabilités à certains moments il
aurait dû dire à sa majorité à ses
ministres à ses soutiens ou à d'autres
partenaires au patronat aux syndicats
l'instant défaite fait le montrer ce que
vous savez faire
nicolas est un homme généreux et quand
ils voient qu'il ya un problème il faut
le régler lui même de temps en temps il
faut savoir dire aux autres allez-y
faites le boulot verrai bien ce que vous
on verra bien ce que vous êtes capable
de faire quand on revient au quinquennat
qui a accentué le côté
présidentialisation du régime avec avec
un septennat un président mitterrand l'a
fait souvent pouvait prendre du recul et
se détacher y compris de son camp y
compris de son gouvernement
d'ailleurs vous souvenez vous de la
phrase de fabius lui c'est lui et moi
c'est moi et ça aller loin et finalement
ça permettait de respirer
aujourd'hui entre avec le quinquennat il
ya plus de moments de respiration
on sait qu'on s'en prend pour cinq ans
de hollande on a été condamné à cinq ans
et voilà et on peut rien faire d'autre
si françois hollande manque d'autorité
naturelle est ce qu'il fait un bon chef
de guerre au point de vue militaire je
dois reconnaître qu'il a pris la bonne
décision au mali celles que l'état major
et préparer ainsi que nous serions pris
si nous n'avions pas été en situation un
de campagne électorale et si la menace
avait été aussi fortes mais il l'a fait
et je suis reconnaissant
françois hollande qui était aussi très
en pointe sur le dossier syrie alors là
c'était je pense je pense qu'il ya eu
une petite erreur diplomatique c'est que
les américains nous ont traités comme
des chiens
je veux dire par là que le nombre total
à un peu quand même parce que si vous
voulez il faut aussi il faut savoir avec
qui on part faire la guerre
parce que si vous partez faire la guerre
avec quelqu'un dont vous pouvez penser
raisonnablement qui n'a pas envie de la
faire vous passer pour une bille et
c'est un petit peu ce qui s'est passé
obama et mais les français tentent les
russes lui claqué la porte au nez
le au moment où les rues sont entrouvert
la porte il a laissé tomber les français
il faut s'en souvenir
il aurait fallu être plus prudent ou
plus exactement comme l'a dit françois
fillon
et je partage totalement sentiment faire
ce que l'ago france a toujours fait
parler ou russes et vos amérique
justement françois fillon lui il a parlé
aux russes il a parlé à poutine en
russie ce que vous avez été choqué que
l'ancien premier ministre que vous
soutenez vous nous avez rappelé au cours
de cette émission
et bien apporte son soutien dirigeant
occidental engagé dans un bras de fer
avec notre pays
là il n'est pas dirigé un homme
politique aujourd'hui il participe
bon en gros sur le cimer poutine en
l'appelant vladimir non je la rejette
dans la france la russie nous a beaucoup
aidés et la russie n'est pas notre
adversaire il se trouve que nous avons
un différend
l'analyse sur la syrie mais ce n'est
qu'un différentes analyses sur la série
la russie est un grand pays et
continental dont une partie est très
clairement européenne et nous ne pouvons
pas rejeter la russie il faut discuter
avec elle en l'espèce suite était un
mois avant même après c'était mieux
c'est un peu trop loin
d'accord il y a deux millions de
réfugiés syriens aujourd'hui est ce que
la france doit en prendre sa part le
qatar je pense que nous ne sommes pas en
mesure de régler la guerre entre les
chiites et sunnites qui depuis le
détroit d'ormuz jusqu'au nord libre au
sud-liban oppose ces deux grandes
cultures
une petite question sur les roms pour
terminer gérard longuet valls a dit il
ya les roms n'ont pas vocation à rester
en france vous partager ce point de vue
ils n'ont pas de volonté d'intégration
ya un vrai problème oui c'est vrai il ya
un vrai problème la france est un pays
de sédentaires ou et individualiste et
la culture communautaire mobile sont
assez largement incompatible avec notre
vie quotidienne pourquoi parce qu'il
faut scolariser les enfants parce que il
faut accepter l'exogamie et non pas loin
d'un gameplay intégrale et il faut
accepter que chaque individu soit libre
et n'appartiennent ni un clan ni à une
tribu ni un pater familias despotique
toute l'histoire de l'humanisme français
avant la révolution et bien après c
était d'afficher la primauté de
l'individu et dans ce vieux pays paysans
la sédentarisation les roms c'est
exactement le contraire c'est le
collectif
le clanique le tribal et la mobilité on
a beaucoup de mal à se comprendre
il ya des réussites
rasséréné il ya des vieilles familles
d'origine manouche entre guillemets
django reinhardt enfin qui existe en
france depuis longtemps qui se sont
intégrés baptisé ceux qui ne veulent pas
accepter nos principes de vie commune
qui sont je le répète l'exogamie c'est à
dire on se marie avec les gens que l'on
connaît pas simplement avec le clan et
on est fixe et on vit dans la vie locale
et on respecte la vie locale parce que
quand vous êtes de passage c'est les
gens qui sont de passage que ce soit
d'ailleurs dit militer en permission ou
des lycéens français dans le sud de
l'angleterre
quand ils sont en séjour scolaire ils se
tiennent parfois un petit peu léger et
bien quand vous êtes une unité
constituée pour avoir été élu local je
peux vous dire que les passages laisse
parfois des séquelles dont considéré
comme il faut pas globaliser mais le
fait est qu'il y à des systèmes à
l'intérieur qu'ils sont et ce qu'ils ne
veulent pas qu'ils ne choisissent pas
l'intégration
merci d'abord été avec nous cette
semaine merci paris la semaine prochaine
notre invité vous l'entendrez et vous
l'écouté avec attention sera françois
bayrou bonsoir est très vite